[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JASON KU: Welcome, everybody,
to the second-to-last lecture
of 6.006.
In this lecture,
we've mostly covered
all of the testable
material that we're
going to have on the
final, or on quiz 3.
Today, really what
we're talking about
is putting into context
all the material
that we've learned over
the course of the term
at a high level and talk about
where we can go from here
in terms of other theory
classes and other classes
in the department that are
related to this material.
Now, most things
in the department
are in some way related
to this material.
And so that's why there's
a foundational course.
But we're going to try to talk
about it from a high level
and talk about how some
future things that you
might be interested relate.
OK, so we started out
the term, in lecture one,
talking about 6.006, and
we had four main goals
that we had for our course--
really three main goals
Does anyone remember
what those goals were?
So you got to the
last one first.
The first one was to solve
hard computational problems,
to be able to solve problems.
So this is kind of like the
"let's make an algorithm"
part of the course.
1, solve hard
computational problems.
I guess "hard" here maybe
should be in quotes because we
saw in the last
lecture what hard
means in a technical sense.
Hard could mean that there's
no efficient algorithm that we
know how to solve a problem on.
That's getting a little
bit of ahead of ourselves.
Computational problems
with algorithms
is really the key
part about this goal.
It's kind of the
same goal that you
have in a class like
6.0001 or 6.009.
You're trying to
convince a computer
that you solved a problem
on a finite set of inputs.
But really what
this class is about
is two other things, which
is more about communication
to people rather than computers.
Your algorithm might be
correct or efficient,
but you need to be able to
communicate that to humans.
And that's what the
other two goals are.
So second one is
argue correctness.
Basically, the thing that
I'm doing to my inputs
is always going to lead
me to a correct output.
No matter what input I
give it, any valid input--
there could be an infinite
space of possible inputs,
and in this class,
that's the case,
because we want our input size
to grow arbitrarily large--
we need to be able
to argue correctness
that it's going to return
me the correct thing
no matter what my inputs are.
And in order to do that, that's
essentially-- that's 6.042.
This whole class has
basically been applied 6.042.
I've given you some
procedures, and you
have to prove things
about these procedures.
Or most of the time,
we proved it for you,
and then you've used
them as black boxes.
But that's a lot of what
this class is about.
And the third one
is efficiency--
argue that it's "good,"
for lack of a better thing.
This is efficiency.
What does "good" mean?
Well, that was hard to know
at the beginning of our class.
And so we set up this model
of computation, a framework,
through which we could
determine how good or bad
our algorithms were by saying--
by defining a model of
computation, saying what things
we can do in constant time, and
then just building off of that.
So this is basically our
model plus some asymptotics
or something like that.
Ran out of space.
What?
AUDIENCE: It's
about scalability.
JASON KU: Yeah, this
is about scalability.
A model of computation tells
us how much time we can spend,
but it's compared
to our input size.
This is always about,
how does our algorithm
perform relative to the rate
that our problem size grows?
And so that's what
we mean by "good."
And in this class, we don't
tend to talk about constant size
problems.
It's about how algorithms
can scale as you
have arbitrarily large inputs.
That's why we need
recursion and induction
to be able to prove things
about our algorithms,
because they're for arbitrary n.
And that's why we need this
relative-to-input size,
the growth factor of our
algorithm's performance,
relative to the input.
OK, and then the
last thing is, to me,
one of the most
important things,
is communicating these
things to another human.
So communication is key here.
If you can always
write good code
that's always
right, good for you.
I can't do that all the time.
But that might mean
that you can be very--
a competent, independent
computer programmer.
But you are going to be limited
in what you can do if you're
only able to rely on yourself.
A lot about computer science
is working with others
to solve computational problems.
And when you're
working with others
to solve computational
problems, you
need to be able to
communicate with them,
and you need to be able
to communicate them both
what it is you're doing and
why it is you're doing it--
that you're doing the correct
thing and that it's efficient.
And so that's a big part
about what this course is.
At the end of the
day, on your quiz,
if you write down Python
script for a correct algorithm,
but we don't know
what it's doing,
but it's correct,
we're not going
to give you full points on that,
because you're not satisfying
the conditions of this class.
It's really about the
communication here.
OK, so just to review,
since we've not
discussed how the most recent
lecture fits into your problem
sets.
We didn't have any problem
sets that covered complexity,
so how does that fit in?
Well, argue that the ways that
we're solving our problems
are good.
What we proved in the last
lecture was that most problems
cannot be solved good.
They can't be solved
in polynomial time
with respect to the
size of your input.
However, most of the
problems that we think about,
in a sense, I can prove to
you that it's a yes solution.
I can show you a simple
path in this graph that
has a certain length.
Or I can show you a subset
that sums to a certain value
in a particular problem.
I can give you a
certificate that I
can prove to you in a
reasonable amount of time
that, yes, I can
prove to you that this
is-- the answer to
this thing is correct.
And that's what we talked
about in the last lecture.
So not always "good"
algorithms to solve problems,
but many problems we think
about can be either checked
in polynomial time--
this is the concept of having
a certificate that I could give
you of polynomial
size that could
be checked in polynomial time--
in a sense, that's a way--
check-- checked in
polynomial time.
This leads to our class
of decision problems, NP.
Or it can be solved by brute
force in exponential time.
Most of the things that we've
talked about in this class
fall into one of
these two categories.
We can just brute force
over the combinatorial space
of possible outputs and check
to see if they're correct.
Or I can give you a certificate
basically saying, look,
I can solve--
actually, anything
that's of this form
can be checked in this
form, because there's
only a polynomial number of
things to check-- or, sorry,
an exponential possible
number of certificates
of polynomial length to check.
But basically, this is
saying that the problems
that we think of mostly fall
into these two categories.
And so there usually
are algorithms to solve
the problems that
we care about, even
if most random problems
in terms of bit strings
that we gave an analysis
in the last lecture
actually prove that most random
problems are not solvable.
In a sense, the problems we
think about are not random.
They kind of have this
structure that they
can be checked pretty quickly.
OK, so that's what
we mean when we
are talking about complexity.
For the purposes of
the final, you'll
be able to see on your
final exam practice problems
that we're going to give you,
most of what we cover in terms
of material on the final
that will be testing
the lecture 19 material will
be in terms of the definitions.
Do you understand what the
decision problem class NP is?
EXP is?
Do you know how these
relate to each other?
EXP is definitely a
superset of NP here.
NP nestles inside here.
They could be
equal-- probably not.
Those are the types of
things that we would address.
Knowing a directionality
of a reduction.
If you have a problem
A and a problem
B, and I know that this one
is difficult by some measure--
I already happened to
know that it's very hard,
like NP-hard or
something like that.
If this is a problem that
I'm interested in knowing
the complexity about,
and I can prove
that I can solve it if I
had a black box to solve B--
any black box to
solve B, and I could
make this reduction
in polynomial time,
and if this is hard, that
means this can't be--
that means that if
this is hard, then
I better not be able to solve
this in polynomial time,
because then I would be able to
solve this in polynomial time.
So that's basically
the type of argument
usually in a
true/false question we
might have on the
final exam for you
to kind of understand the basic
high-level definitions involved
in what was talked
about in lecture 19.
Hardness-- the very most
difficult problems of these
classes--
and completeness--
sorry, anything harder
than things in these classes.
Whereas completeness is
the ones that are in this
set, but at least as hard as
anything in those classes.
So that's just to give
you a brief overview
of the only material
that hasn't been tested
but might be tested
on the final.
So when we don't have
a good algorithm,
we can actually prove
that it probably
doesn't have a good algorithm.
And that's a problem
that you'll be
able to solve in
future classes, if you
continue along this track.
OK, so what's the actual
content that we talked about?
This is a very
high-level overview
of why we're taking this class,
why you're taking this class.
But what is the content
we actually covered?
I like to break it up into
three units and, in a sense,
two subunits.
So quiz 1 material and quiz 2
material was about showing you
some nice black boxes.
Basically, if I'm going to have
inputs of non-constant size,
it's going to be useful for
me to be able to find things
among those elements.
So that's really what
quiz 1 is all about--
data structures
for finding things
in non-constant size database.
Sure.
And when we were
storing these things,
we want to support maybe two
different types of queries--
ones that were intrinsic to
the items, what the items were,
and ones based on what--
an extrinsic order
was placed on these items.
And that was a way in
which we broke down,
how should I approach
looking at this problem?
I want to be able to
support queries and maintain
an extrinsic order
on these things.
I might want a sequence.
This is a sequence
extrinsic order.
Or I want to be able to look
up, is this thing in my set,
by a key that we identify,
with a unique key.
So this is some intrinsic
queries, and often order.
A hash table doesn't maintain
any order on my keys.
But it does support
intrinsic queries--
is this thing in my set or not?
But we did show you
other set data structures
that do support an
intrinsic order that
allows me to see what the next
larger and the next previous--
the next larger and the next
smaller item is in my set.
So here's a summary of those
data structures that we had.
I'm not going to go into
how to use these things
or how to choose
from among them here.
That's what your quiz 1
review lecture was all about.
But basically, the idea here
is, if we have a sequence,
most of the time when
you're programming,
being able to push and
pop at the end of a list
is pretty good.
Which is why Python, the
most fundamental data
structure that you have,
is a list, because it's
a super useful thing.
I just want to store
a bunch of things,
have random access to the,
say, 10th element to my thing,
but I'm not necessarily
having to dynamically update
the order of these
things dynamically.
I don't necessarily
have to insert something
in the middle of the list.
But most of the
time, what I can do
is put it at the end of the
list and maybe swap it down
into place if I need to.
So that's why a list
is super useful.
A sequence AVL tree,
useful, but not
as ubiquitous as a linked list--
I mean, as a dynamic
array, sorry.
I said linked list,
I meant Python list,
which is a dynamic array.
So the dynamic
array tended to be,
in your coding practice, your
most common sequence data
structure here.
Though, we can get pretty
good for this insert
in the middle operation
with the sequence AVL.
OK, then on the set
data structure side,
I categorize these things into
a couple different categories
here in terms of the operations
we can support on these things.
These are all intrinsic
operations-- finding things,
inserting, deleting things.
I think of the first three as
being dictionary operations.
I want to just look up
whether something's there.
Whereas the last two are
order-preserving operations,
where it matters what the order
of these things are stored in.
And so as you can see from
the asymptotic complexity
of the various operations
here, the hash table
is actually super good if you
want the dictionary oper--
if you just want to support
dictionary operations.
But in the cases where you need
to maintain order dynamically,
a set AVL is the way to go.
But if you don't
need it dynamic,
but you still need
those order operations,
a sorted array is
just good enough
if you don't need to
change what they are.
So that's a quick overview of
quiz 1-type data structures
material.
But then we used most
of these data structures
to get faster sorting algorithms
in different contexts.
Basically, everything
on this list
involved making a data structure
and exploiting that data
structure to get a
better running time,
all except for
merge sort, really.
The first two we presented
in terms of a priority queue,
whether we used a sorted
array or an array.
We represented it at
the end of lecture eight
to get n-squared running time.
We generalized that down
to n log n by using a heap.
That was a nice optimization.
But we also got interesting
data structures using an--
I mean, interesting sorting
algorithms using an AVL tree
because of the
power of maintaining
a dynamic order over time.
But then exploiting a direct
access array to be able to sort
in linear time for
small-bounded--
bounded in terms of
the input, polynomially
bounded in terms of the
input-- ranges of numbers.
So we leverage that direct axis
array to get counting sort.
And then we kind of
amplified that effect
by sorting on a bunch
of digits multiple times
to get basically polynomial
blow-up in terms of the numbers
that we could sort
in linear time.
So that's an overview of
the content of quiz 1.
In quiz 2, we were kind
of like, OK, now you
know how to find things
within a set of just
a flat list of things, you can
put it in a data structure.
But in a sense, a graph is a
special kind of data structure
that relates the different
things in your input.
So if you've got a
bunch of vertices,
there's a relation now
between those vertices
that are your edges.
And this is a super
useful framework
in talking about
discrete systems,
because you can
think of a vertex
as a state of your system, and
then connect these transitions
as a graph.
That's the reason why--
I mean, graphs are
awesome, but they're
awesome because they
can be used to model
so many different
things within our world.
It's not just about
road networks.
It can also be about playing
your favorite turn-based game,
like Tilt.
OK, so we talked about a lot
of different types of problems
that you could solve,
various algorithms,
with a focus on a bunch of
different ways of solving
single-source shortest paths.
And again, just like
the sorting algorithms
and just like the
data structures,
we presented multiple
of them, because we
had this trade-off of
generality of the graph
that they apply to contrasted
with the running time.
So I guess, in
particular, the top line
there is, in some sense,
the most restrictive.
We don't have any
cycles in our graph.
That's a very special
type of graph,
and we're able to
get linear time.
But then even if we do
have cycles in our graph,
we can do better if we
have a bound on the weights
in our thing, whether they be--
there's an easy conversion
to a linear time algorithm
via an unweighted process,
or whether these things are
non-negative, so there can't
be negative weight cycles,
and we don't have
to deal with that.
OK, so that's quiz 2 material.
And then quiz 3
material was kind
of applying this graph material
to a recursive framework.
What was our
recursive framework?
Everyone say it with me.
AUDIENCE: Dynamic programming.
JASON KU: Dynamic
programming, and the framework
was SRT BOT, right?
Missing a letter,
but SORT BOT, right?
You can actually
think of the quiz 3
material as really an
application of the graph
material.
What are we doing in SORT BOT?
We're defining a
set of subproblems.
These are a set of
vertices in a graph.
What is the relationship doing?
It's saying, what
are the relation
between the
subproblems, essentially
defining the edges of a graph?
And then this topological
order and the base cases,
all of these things
are just saying,
what is the problem that I
want to solve on this graph?
And how do I compute
that for things that
don't have any outgoing edges?
I need to start writing
on the board again.
This is graphs.
There was sorting in here, too.
This is basically
an application.
OK, graphs was
basically a relationship
on these non-constant things.
So this was kind of
like useful black boxes
that you can just bundle up
and stick in some inputs,
stick out some outputs,
and you're golden.
Whereas quiz 3 was
very different,
the material in quiz
3 is very different.
Dynamic programming, while
it was, in some sense,
related to this graph material--
I'm constructing a graph--
I have to construct that graph.
There's a creative process in
trying to construct that graph.
I don't give you
a set of vertices.
Usually what I give
you are a set of--
a sequence or
something like that.
And you have to construct
vertices, subproblems,
that will be able to be
related in a recursive way
so you can solve the problem.
This is a very much
more difficult thing
than these other
things, I think,
because there's a lot
more creativity in this.
In the same way
that just applying--
reducing to the graph algorithms
we have is fairly easy.
But actually doing some
graph transformations
to change the shape
of the graph so
that you can apply
these algorithms, that's
a harder thing to do.
The difficulty with these
two sets of materials
is very similar.
Figuring out what
the graph should be,
figuring out what the
subproblems should be
and how they relate, is really
the entire part of the--
the entire difficulty with
solving problems recursively.
And we've only given you a
taste of solving problems
recursively.
In future classes,
like 6.046, which
is the follow-on to this one in
the undergraduate curriculum,
this is all about
introduction to algorithms.
The next one's about design
and analysis of algorithms.
It's quite a bit more
difficult, because we've mostly
left it to you to use the
things that we gave you
or make your own
algorithms based
on this very nice
cookbook-like framework
that you can plug in a
recursive algorithm to.
Now actually, that
cookbook is super
nice for any way of looking
at a problem recursively,
but while in
dynamic programming,
the inductive hypothesis of
combining your subproblems
is almost trivial,
in other types
of recursive algorithms, that's
not necessarily the case.
Especially when
instead of looking
at all possible
choices, for example,
in a greedy algorithm
where you're just
looking at one of the choices,
the locally best thing,
and recursing forward, you're
not doing all the work.
You're not locally
brute-forcing.
Your locally picking an optimal
thing locally and hoping that
will lead you to good thing.
That's a much harder algorithmic
paradigm to operate under.
And so that's more
like the material
that you'll be talking
about in 6.046.
So that's 006, a very quick
overview of the content of this
class.
And we really like the structure
of how this class is laid out,
because it gives you a
fundamental idea of the things
people use to store information
on a computer and a sense
of how you solve
problems computationally
and how to argue that they're
correct and efficient.
That's really what
this problem--
this course is about.
And if you feel like you
enjoy this kind of stuff,
that's where you
go to take 6.046.
And 6.046 was actually
the first algorithms class
I ever took here at MIT,
as a grad student actually.
This was hard for me.
It's actually hard to look at
these problems, these types,
and think in a
computational way,
especially having not
taken this class, 6.006.
So hopefully you guys are
all in a better position
than I was when I took it.
There's two ways I like to
think of the content in 6.046.
One is kind of just as
an extension of 006.
It's the natural
follow-on to the things
that we do in this class.
They still talk about
data structures.
This isn't the core part of
046, but they do touch on data
structures for
more complicated--
that have more complicated
analyses involved in them.
It's really about--
usually in 046,
stating what the algorithm
is doing is not so hard.
Basically, giving
you the algorithm,
number one here, is
not so difficult,
to state what's happening
in the algorithm.
But the number two
and number three here,
arguing that that thing is
correct and arguing that thing
is efficient, that's where the
complexity comes in in 046.
The analysis part is quite a
bit more complicated in 046 than
in 006.
So they solve a problem called
union-find and give a much--
we talked a little bit
about amortization.
This goes into a much better-- a
much more formal way of proving
things run in amortized time.
So this is basically
amortization via what
we call a potential analysis.
It's basically
making that notion
that we talked about
when we were talking
about dynamic arrays of, we're
not doing this expensive thing
too often.
Basically what we
do is we keep track
of the cost of all
sequence of operations
and prove that the
average cost is small.
That's kind of what this
potential analysis is doing.
It's a little bit
more formal process
for making that argument
a little more formal.
Right.
OK.
So then on the
graph side, this is
kind of an extension of
quiz 1-type material.
This is, what is this
union-find data structure?
It's basically-- it's
a set type thing, where
I can make a set of
just a single element,
I can take two sets, merge
them together, make them
their union, and then
given an object, I say,
which set am I part of,
essentially by electing
a leader within
a set and saying,
return me a pointer to that one.
And so this can be useful
in dynamically maintaining,
say, the connected components
in a dynamically changing graph
supporting the query of,
am I in the same component
as this other guy?
That could be a very useful
thing to know about a graph
as it's changing.
So that's an application
of this problem.
And they get
near-constant performance
for a lot of these queries.
It's not quite,
but pretty close.
OK, on the graph
side, they solve
a number of very useful
problems on graphs.
Minimum Spanning
Tree-- so I'm trying
to find a tree connecting
all of the vertices
in a connected
component of my graph.
And I'm trying to find--
in a weighted graph,
I'm trying to find
the spanning tree that
has minimum total weight.
So that's a problem--
a fundamental problem in
weighted-graph algorithms.
They've solved this
via a greedy algorithm.
And network flows
and I guess cuts.
So this is-- what is this?
This is, I'm given
a weighted graph.
Basically, each of the weights
correspond to a capacity.
I could push water
through along this edge.
And I may be given a source
vertex and a sink vertex.
And I want to say, I
want to shove water
through the source
vertex along the edges
with their various capacities.
And I'll get some
amount of water
on the other end in the source.
So the question is, what's
the most amount of water
that I can push through this?
Well, I could build
that pipe network
with the different things and
just do this experimentally.
I just stick a bunch of--
maybe-- I'm a
mechanical engineer,
so that maybe makes sense to me.
But you want to be able to
just look at those numbers
and be able to tell me how
much water can I push through.
That's what the max flow in
a network is talking about.
And we give you some polynomial
time algorithms in this class,
basically incremental algorithms
that, kind of like Dijkstra,
or kind of like Bellman-Ford,
will incrementally update
estimates to--
of a max flow and
improve them over time.
Then on the, basically,
design paradigms,
you've got more involved making
your own divide-and-conquer
algorithms, dynamic programming
algorithms, greedy algorithms.
Basically, they go
a lot more in depth
in terms of how to design these
algorithms and these paradigms
than we do in this class.
And then the last thing is--
we only touched on complexity.
And in a sense, 046 is only
going to touch on complexity.
It's a very big field.
But it will give
you the tools to be
able to prove that something is
NP-hard, whereas we just kind
of say that, oh, there's this
thing called a reduction.
We didn't give you any
problems in which you actually
had to reduce one
problem to another.
And you'll do a lot
more of that here.
So, reductions.
So in a big sense, 046 is
really just a natural extension
to the 006 material, plus
some additional stuff,
which I'm going to
get to in a second.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Do you want
to add randomization
for time paradigms?
JASON KU: I'm going
to talk about that
slightly in a separate--
I'll get to your question
in just a second.
I like to think of it as
a separate topic, which
I will go into right now.
The separate topic I like
to think of it as, instead
of being the natural extension
to the things in the 006 units,
what I'm going to do is kind
of relax either what it means
to have a correct algorithm
or relax what it means to--
what my model of computation is.
So 006, this is kind of
as an extension of 006.
And this is kind of
like 6.046 as change
my definition of what it means
to be correct or efficient.
So we've already kind of done
this a little bit in 006.
Basically, one of the
things that we can do,
which is what the question
that a student asked a question
about, was about
randomized algorithms,
which is a big part
of 046 actually--
randomized analysis
of algorithms
that are not deterministic.
It's not guaranteed that
it'll give you the same output
every time or not
guaranteed that it
will do the same
computations over the course
of the algorithm every time.
But it exploits
some randomization.
And in 006, this is--
we've mostly not touched on
this, except in one area.
Where did we use randomization?
In hashing, right?
When we used hashing,
what were we doing?
We changed the definition
of correct versus efficient.
We didn't really change the
definition, what we did was
we said that it was OK that
sometimes our algorithm was
slower than we--
than on-- in expectation.
That's what we meant there.
We're relaxing the
idea of efficient,
but we're still saying
it's good, because most
of the time it is good.
So there's two types of
randomized algorithms.
They have these
weird names based
on betting regions of
the world, shall we say?
There are-- this is L-O?
Los Vegas?
It is Las, OK, Vegas algorithms.
These are always correct,
but probably efficient.
In a sense, that's
what hashing is.
I'm always going to give
you the right thing,
whether this thing
is in my set or not.
But some of the time,
it's inefficient.
I have to look through
a chain of length
of-- that's linear in the size
of the things that I'm storing.
And this is in contrast to
a Monte Carlo algorithm,
which is always efficient for
some definition of efficient,
but only probably correct.
And I mean, I could define you a
hash table that has Monte Carlo
semantics instead.
Say, for example, I
say that I'm going--
it's going to be exactly
the same as a hash table,
except instead of storing
all the things that
collide in a place, I just
store the first two, say.
Well, actually, that's actually
going to be always efficient.
I'm going to look
through the things
and see if it's in there.
And the chains that I'm storing
there only have two things.
It's going to be
always efficient.
It's always going to
give me constant time.
But some of the time, it's
going to be the wrong thing,
because I'm not storing
everything in that chain.
So there's some probability that
that's not going to be correct.
And so that's a
different kind of--
maybe I want my hash
tables to always be fast,
but I can afford to be
wrong some of the time.
I don't know.
In practice, this is actually
sometimes a good trade-off
in real systems.
Sometimes it's OK to be
wrong some of the times,
if we get good performance.
OK, but generally can do better
if you allow randomization.
And by better I mean, usually
we can get faster bounds
on a lot of problems if we allow
randomization and things aren't
necessarily always correct
or always efficient.
So this is a big area in
046 that requires a lot more
analysis using randomness
and probability.
So if you need some
primers on that--
we didn't have a lot of this in
006, but if you go on to 046,
that's going to be a really
important thing for you
to brush up on.
The next part on 006 is kind
of changing what our definition
of correct or efficient means.
I mean, we've
restricted ourselves
in this class to a class
of problems where we only
talk about integers.
But there's tons of
problems in this world,
especially in
scientific computing,
where I want to be able to find
out what this real number is.
And I can't even store a
real number on my computer.
So what the hell, Jason?
What are you talking about?
I can't do that on a computer.
But what I can do is
basically compute things
in a numerical sense--
numerical algorithms.
And in 046, a lot of times
we put this in the context
of continuous optimization,
continuous being the opportune
word here, not discrete systems.
You have a continuum of
possible solutions, real numbers
essentially.
How do we do this on a computer
that's a discrete system?
Basically, in 046
what you can do,
and in other numerical methods
classes, what you can say is,
well, I know that you can't
return me a real number.
I got that.
Or you can maybe have
a model of computation
that allows integers
to represent
other kinds of real numbers,
like radicals or rationals
or something like that.
And I can do
manipulations on those.
But really what these
algorithms are usually about
is computing real
numbers not completely,
but to some bounded precision.
And I pay for that precision.
The more bits of precision
I want on my number,
I have to pay for them.
So this is basic--
I think of these as
an approximation--
approximation of real
number to some precision,
and I pay for
precision with time.
So let's say I wanted to compute
the square root of a number.
I could have an algorithm
just like the algorithms--
or I guess division,
right, long division.
You all know the algorithm
of long division.
You put the quotient under
here with these-- an AB
and you get the C
on top or whatever.
That's an algorithm.
That's a procedure using
essentially small numbers.
I'm only talking about
the digits zero to nine
here when I'm doing
that algorithm.
So it's a procedure
that only uses
small integers to
compute arbitrary
precision of a division.
So that's an
algorithm, and I have
to pay time to get more digits.
So that's an
example of this kind
of-- how we live in the
world of real numbers
when all we have is
a discrete system.
And then the last category
I'd like to talk about here
is really approximation
algorithms.
Whereas this is kind of an
approximation algorithm,
I'm approximating
my outputs, this
is an approximation algorithm
from the standpoint of,
well, there's a lot of problems
that I can't solve efficiently.
They're NP-hard.
They're in EXP or
even harder problems.
But maybe I'm OK with not
getting the optimal solution.
So this is in the domain
of optimization problems.
So most of the
dynamic programming
problems that we gave you
were optimization problems.
They're the shortest
paths problems.
Those are optimization problems.
Basically, the possible outputs
are ranked in some way--
the distance of a path that you
return or something like that.
They're ranked in some way.
There is an optimal one--
the one with the smallest
metric or something like that.
Well, in an approximation
algorithm what I do is, OK,
I get that it's computationally
difficult for you
to give me the longest
simple path in this graph,
or the shortest possible route
for my traveling salesman,
but maybe that's OK.
I mean, my engineering
Spidey-sense
tells me that
within 10% is fine.
So maybe instead of giving
me the most optimal thing,
can I give you an
algorithm that's
guaranteed to be within
a certain distance
from the optimal thing?
Usually, we're looking for
constant factor approximations
which have low
constant, or maybe
even have to do for worse
if such things don't exist.
OK, so that's
approximation algorithms.
Can we get close to an optimal
solution in polynomial time?
OK.
And then the last way we could
change things in, especially
future classes, though sometimes
they talk about this in 046
as well, is we could change
the model of computation.
We could basically change
something about our computer
to be put in some other weird
paradigm of solving problems
with more power
essentially, or you're
in a situation where
there's less power.
OK, so change in the
model of computation.
So what we've been talking
to you in terms of model
of computation is our word-RAM--
word-RAM.
And that essentially says I
can do arithmetic operations,
and I can look up stuff in
my memory in constant time.
And but if I allocate
a certain amount,
I have to pay that amount
and that kind of thing.
So that's this word-RAM model.
But in actuality, all
of your computers,
it's a lot easier
for me to figure--
to find and read memory
that's on my CPU in a register
than it is for me to go out
to the hard disk, ask this--
well, in my day, it used to be
this movable mechanical head
that had to go and scan
over a bit on a CD-ROM drive
and actually read
what that thing was.
So we can add
complexity to our model
to better account for the costs
of operations on my machine.
One of those models is
called the cache model--
cache model.
It's basically a
hierarchy of memory.
I have my registers
on board my CPU.
I have maybe an L1 cache
that's close to my CPU.
Then I have another
set of caches
and another set of
caches maybe out to RAM.
And reading from a hard disk, a
solid state drive of some kind,
that's the slowest
thing to access.
And I can put a cost associated
with each of those things.
And instead of having to--
having all of our operations
be said to be constant,
the constants are
actually different,
and I have to pay
for that difference.
And so that's
extending our model
to be a little bit more
realistic to our machine.
Another one is we have
computers right now that
operate in classical
physics, that exploit
things in classical physics.
But in actuality,
our world allows
for even more complicated
types of operations,
like quantum operations, where
you're exploiting entanglement
and superposition
of different atoms
to potentially get operations
that I can act on my data that
are actually provably stronger
than the classical models
in some sense.
So this is a huge
reason why there's
a lot of work
being done in, say,
lots of industry research
facilities in figuring out
these models.
Because maybe if you can make
a big enough quantum computer,
you can break encryption and
stuff in polynomial time.
And that's something that
maybe the NSA is interested in.
And I'm not going
to go into that.
But, you know.
I mean, some people--
you look at artificial
intelligence and things like
discussions around
artificial intelligence,
my brain might be doing things
that a classical computer
cannot.
It could be using quantum
superposition in some way.
And our computers that are
in your phone and your laptop
and things like that aren't
exploiting those operations,
so how could we ever
get intelligence,
because in some sense, our
brains are more powerful.
And so a lot of what AI
should be looking into
is, what is the actual model
of computation of our brains
that can give us the
power to have sentience?
OK, so that's kind
of quantum computing.
I don't know much
about it actually.
And then there's things like,
maybe I have more than one CPU.
I mean, most computers--
all the computers you have,
even the ones in your phone,
probably have multiple cores.
In a sense, you have lots
of CPUs running in parallel.
So this is like par--
there's one R in parallel?
Parallel computing basically
says, it's cheap for me
to make another
computer potentially.
If I have two computers
running on the same problem,
maybe I can get a
two-fold speed-up on my--
on the time in which it
takes to solve my problem.
Now, suppose I had then 100
CPUs running on a machine.
Maybe I can get
100-fold speed-up.
And actually, in real
life, 100-fold speed-up
makes a difference.
It's, am I waiting for
this for 10 minutes?
Or am I waiting for
this for 1,000 minutes?
That's, like, all day.
I don't want to do that.
Maybe it's on weeks.
I don't even remember.
But parallel computing, if I
can get a 100-fold speed-up,
that might be a huge win.
But for some problems,
it's not possible--
if I have k CPUs, can I
get a k-factor speed-up?
It's not always possible to do.
And so parallel computing
is another paradigm
in which there's a lot of
interesting theory going on.
There's a lot of
complications there,
because there are a
couple different models.
You can have multicore
set-up, where
you have a lot of computers
that are accessing
the same bank of memory.
And then you don't want them
all to be reading and writing
from them at different times,
because you don't necessarily
know what their state is,
and you get these collisions,
which are something
that you really have
to think about in this world.
Or you have situations
where maybe I
have a bunch of
nano-flies or something
that are going around, and
they have very small computer
brains themselves.
But they can talk to each
other and pass information
to each other, but
they don't have access
to one central network
repository of information.
That's what we call a
distributed parallel system,
where all of the
CPUs that you have
can interact with each
other maybe locally,
but don't have access to
the same memory system.
So they have to work
together to learn information
about the system.
OK, so that's a brief overview
of the different directions
this class, 6.006,
and theory in general,
could lead you-- into a huge
array of different branches
theory and different
problems that you
could address with different
types of computers.
So I know this is a very
high-level lecture and maybe
less-applied than some
of you might like.
But I hope this gives you a good
understanding of the directions
you can go after this
class that I think
are really excited in terms
of how to solve problems
computationally.
So with that, I'd
like to end there.